على مدى العامين الماضيين ،
كان على قطاع السفر والسياحة اجتياز
الصدمات والاضطرابات غير المسبوقة الآن
هنا في دبي ، جاء قادة الصناعة من 112
وجهة عالمية
لمناقشة مستقبل الصناعة الآن وفقًا
لإنفاق مجلس السفر والسياحة العالمي
على سفر الأعمال.  من المتوقع
أن يرتفع بنسبة 32 في المائة في الشرق الأوسط ،
أخبرني كبير الاقتصاديين في شركة
أكسفورد للاقتصاد ، سكوت ليفرمور ،
عن توقعات السفر والسياحة في
المنطقة ،
وأعتقد أن المكان الذي نعيش فيه الآن نشهد
انتعاشًا قويًا في سياحة السفر
في المنطقة.
قطاع سياحة السفر الداخلي الذي شهد
ارتفاعًا ملحوظًا ، وهذا
مستقبل جديد تمامًا للمنطقة
قبل الأزمة ، حوالي 55 في المائة من
سياحة السفر محلية ،
وارتفعت الأسعار إلى 80 في المائة من الناس ،
لذا فإن الناس يسافرون
داخليًا ، لذلك أنت  رؤية
السياحة المحلية تدفع النمو في الوقت الحالي بشكل
مطلق وتدعم هذا القطاع
بينما هؤلاء يسيرون  قد ينخفض ​​نظام ios نظرًا لأن
السفر الدولي يصبح أمرًا
طبيعيًا وتخفيف القيود المفروضة على اللقاحات ،
ونتوقع استمرار هذا
التغيير التجاري ونتوقع أن يكون هناك دور أكبر
للسفر المحلي والسياحة في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة
بما في ذلك دول مثل الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي كانت
تعتمد في الغالب  على الزوار الدوليين الذين
تعرفهم أن الإمارات العربية المتحدة
كانت دائمًا نوعًا من أفضل
الوجهات لأنها وجهة معروفة جدًا ، إنها وجهة سهلة
تعتقد أنها ستصعد إلى القمة في
العام المقبل أو نحو ذلك
خلال العام المقبل أو نحو ذلك  أعتقد
أننا سنشهد نموًا قويًا حقًا في دولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، وأعتقد أنهم قاموا ببناء
البنية التحتية التي لديهم قاعدة صلبة
وقطاع السفر
والسياحة الناجح بالفعل ، ثم هناك
خطة طموحة سواء أكانت هتا بيرة أبو
ظبي أو  عبر الإمارات الأخرى ، لذا فأنت ترى
مقارنة بالمنافسة بين
الإمارات داخل دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
.
مناطق مختلفة للتركيز على تفضيلات
المستهلك والأمر كله يتعلق
بتمييز نفسك في اقتطاع
مكانتك والاستماع إلى ما
يقوله المستهلك ثم الاستجابة
لذلك وتقديمه ، وأعتقد
أننا سنشهد طلبًا سياحيًا أكثر تميزًا
وتنوعًا حول
العالم وهذا يعطي المجال والفرص
لمختلف البلدان داخل
المنطقة ، انظر إلى أنك خبير اقتصادي ، لذا
فأنت تنظر إلى الأرقام بشكل صحيح
وعندما ترى أن سعر النفط يصل إلى
المستويات حيث يجعل
الطيران أكثر تكلفة ، فأنت
قلق بشأنه  التأثير الضار على
وجه التحديد للسفر الدولي
أعتقد أن هناك
جانبًا مقلقًا وجانبًا متفائلًا
لأن المنطقة تعتمد بشكل رهيب جدًا
على السفر لمسافات متوسطة إلى طويلة ، لذا فإن حوالي
ثلثي الزوار الدوليين إلى
الشرق الأوسط مصنفون على أنهم متوسطو
لمسافات طويلة مقارنة بـ 40 بالنسبة
للعالم ككل ، وسيشهد السفر لمسافات طويلة
أكبر تأثير
من ارتفاع أسعار النفط  وثانيًا ارتفاع أسعار
تذاكر الطيران وهذا يمكن أن يحد حقًا من
الطلب على السفر لمسافات طويلة والذي
يعتمد بشدة على هذه المنطقة
ولكن من ناحية أخرى ، فإن
أسعار النفط المرتفعة ستعزز حقًا
الإيرادات الحكومية التي تميل إلى
إعادة التدوير وستفيد الدخل والنمو
في بلدان المدارس القديمة  ومن
المحتمل أن يؤدي ذلك إلى زيادة الطلب ،
وخاصة الرحلات القصيرة المدى في السفر الإقليمي